Hình thường khiến phương ánh bảo vệ đại hội rằng
Lưu lượng một một trụ đốc xây dựng kế hoạch tôn tra khiểm soát khép kính địa văn
Đà bảo sánh sàng sửi mọi tình mũ phá xinh.
Trang thế bị phương tệ nghiệp vụ được kiểm tra kiến lượng
Từ vũ khí hỗ trợ phương tệ chuyên dục cho tới hệ thống thông tí lên lặng
Nhằm bảo đảng hiệu quả cao nhất trong thực hiện nghiệp vụ.
Tùng tụi bảo chí ra các tổ thông tác cao tùng khai và có thể biệt
Nhưng bụt là có tác tổ biệt là tổ biệt là tổ chá và lắm tình nhời nhìn khá.
Hình thả nghĩ cái đủ trợ mà có hả in vi và pháp.
Tùng tổ chá thương quyết có như thế là nhắn chắc và sẽ chân nấp.
Và trong video thì có tổ, tổ khai sẽ tiếp cạnh tổ biệt.
Trên áp ở đây là tổ khá đường phố, sẽ là trên đường phần công.
Trong là dính dụt tổ bình là mình vụ trong cái thời gian với tổ là để có hơi sự gia đại hội.
Bạn hả, còn có lần trước khi bốn là bị giữ bình dự cho tổng tác tổ biệt.
Là lửa lưu lực công khai tổng chá kìm pháp trên đường tuyền bình dựng cho dân và gà bảo.
Chứ tự án tòa ngon số trong cái gíng ra đại hội với mình vốn rạng.
Vyệt tôn chá khách kiến không chỉ nhằm phát hiện sự lý các hành vi vý phạm chẳt tự án tòa ngon sấu thông.
Mà góng kì tự ngăn chẳng có vụ việc phản pháp vị sự.
Đọc miệt là tình chẳng các nhóm thành kêu điên tụ tập mang theo hôn khí, với giữ trở từ công cầu.
Chả ra bản kí bốn tổ, không đặc kéo.
Học thiệt lực khác về vụ giật và bị chất nghiêm trọng.
Vì là các vụ trợ thẳng chứ, chả thách mặt vý, tự nhiên xong, vụ ký tổ sơ công phụ.
Với chính thần chẳng giệm tạo xử đồng và cuối thăm của người nửa một tụi một công phần thạnh của hà nội.
Công thắc tình thận sao cái tiếng dịa bản thiết thup phân nghi hiệu quả.
Vụ giữ hà nguyên hà nguyên, anh coàn tuyệt đối, có phần vào thay công trung của đại hội đại biểu tăng khóc lần.
hướng mấy bố nguồn đăng.